it's really useful to not defend
yourself to vociferously which is weird
cuz you'd think more you have the right
to defend yourself like no all
no-holds-barred it's like Noah Agri see
doesn't work that way you have to defend
yourself with minimal necessary force
and I think I managed that in the
channel for interview thank God yeah but
I mean believe me people have been
talking to me about that no one stopped
for 15 months and I'm listening and it
wouldn't worked as well if you hadn't
done that
right if you just shall act her right if
you if you just gotten right at her and
said what you are saying is so stupid
for these five reasons it would it would
have been bad I think I think the fact
that you sat there and you just said no
you're asking good questions and you
know the fact that you're asking good
questions demonstrates the invalidity of
your entire view boy that was much more
effective right right well not see see
one of the things I've been meditating
on for the last years there's a line in
the New Testament says resist not evil
think okay what they are you supposed to
do that why it's like because it's
really a difficult thing to figure out
do you really mean that you don't resist
evil well there's a couple of problems
is if you punch back then you have a
fight well but you can't just not defend
yourself like weakly you can't be weak
and not defend yourself but you can be
strong and defend yourself minimally and
that's a real art like that's that's the
essence of sophistication I would say
and like I'm not you know I come from
kind of a rough place I've come from
northern Alberta I come from the
frontier you know and my town was
scraped out of the bloody Prairie 50
years before people moved before before
I lived there and so it's it's been and
it's been a continual challenge to
adjust my sophistication to the level of
challenge and I've I'm trying to do that
and do you think but I don't always
manage it yeah so to that point do you
think that we sometimes actually at a
deep level use identity politics against
ourselves in in this regard so you're
sitting across from Kathy she's female
yeah at some level do you think you may
be moderated it because of that because
had it been a male you know and you and
you talked about this often that we have
to
differently towards males and females
and there's a physical there's physical
reasons for that and biological reasons
for that but that had she been a male
say say the same exact age from you from
Alberta yeah all of that that perhaps
your response might have been a little
more forceful even even though you're
we're all agreeing your response was
done correctly yeah and even handedly
yeah well I it's hard to say but
probably yes that's interesting well
because you did like I can't I don't
think that you can say that you fight
with a woman the same way that you fight
with a man that doesn't mean you can't
fight with a woman doesn't mean you
shouldn't but I don't think the rules
are the same now why are the rules
different well some of the rules are
there's a physical limit it's much more
stringent right I mean there's a level
of hinting at physical threat that you
can bring to bear in a conversation
between men that you cannot bring to
bear in a conversation with a woman
mm-hmm so and the mech mechanics of that
are very very subtle and difficult and
it's especially challenging in an
intellectual discussion because an
intellectual discussion is a kind of war
and it isn't obvious how men and women
should go to war with one another we
don't know we don't know how to sort
that out you my sense has been on the
panels that I've done is that I
definitely have to pull my punches if
I'm on a panel with women it doesn't
mean that I don't it doesn't mean that
it's any less challenging intellectually
but the strategy and the attitude has to
be different it's much more likely that
you'll be seen as a bully if you bring
the same force to bear on a female
opponent as you would on a male opponent